is it explicitly illegal for a president
to sell pardons my research is that it
is not explicitly illegal there is not
an explicit provision that says a
president can't sell pardons or can't
receive benefits in exchange for pardons
benefits could be all sorts of different
things however
and this is where so many of these
issues get complicated there are legal
experts that have said even without an
explicit provision saying you can't sell
a pardon as president
you could indeed as a president selling
pardons be violating other federal laws
bribery you just because you're the
president and you're not explicitly
barred from selling pardons doesn't mean
you couldn't be charged with bribery uh
in accepting money for a pardon